l'objet du délit le foulard plus
précisément le cif marocain que porte
fatima et leïla selon leurs convictions
musulmane
[Musique]
je crois en dieu
je crains de personnes simples dieu je
pense que fulham jusqu'à ma mort
fatima et leïla ont 14 et 13 ans elle
étudie le coran chez elle au tableau
noir depuis l'âge de 3 ans elles font
leurs cinq prières par jour mais leur
but dans la vie c'est aussi de réussir à
l'école
moi je veux continuer mes études je
travaillais fatima et leïla ne sont pas
exclues du collège georges avait semé
l'accès leur en ai refusé tant qu'elles
porteront le foulard pendant les coups
principe de laïcité oblige
est ce cette histoire ce moment qui font
de vous l'homme d'une idée ou d'une
obsession le père et le musulman
en tout cas c'est effectivement avec
cette histoire que je comprends que les
choses ne vont pas se passer
non seulement comme je le croyais jusque
là mais comme cela s'était passé pour
les générations précédentes d'immigrés
c'est à dire
les polonais les italiens les espagnols
les portugais les asiatiques même dans
les années 70 et
nous n'étions pas des immigrés parce que
nous étions français mais c'était un peu
la même logique assimilationniste je
comprends que
l'assimilation à la française va buter
sur une autre machine assimilationniste
qui est beaucoup plus puissante en
vérité surtout que c'est le moment où la
france renonce à ses principes
assimilate assimilationniste qui est
l'islam et je comprends que
ça ne s'agit pas y avoir un affrontement
je ne théorise pas encore l'affrontement
des civilisations qui sera théorisée par
le team tonnes mais c'est un peu l'idée
je comprends qu'il ya sur notre sol deux
civilisations qui vont s'affronter vous
connaissez le le mot célèbre de malraux
casque une civilisation tous qui
s'agrège à une religion et à partir du
moment où
on a ces deux civilisations qui
s'affrontent ça ne peut que que mal se
terminer d'ailleurs on est en 1989 je ne
suis pas le seul à comprendre cela en
1990 donc quelques mois plus tard il y a
une grande convention
du rpr et de l'udf les deux partis de la
droite de l'époque il y à jacques chirac
il y à valéry giscard d'estaing il y à
alain juppé il y à françois bayrou il y
a françois léotard il ya le nicolas
sarkozy
et cette convention de la droite et sur
l'immigration et dans les conclusions de
cette convention du rpr et de l'udf il
est écrit que l'islam est incompatible
avec la france et qu on doit arrêter
l'immigration qu'on doit arrêter le
regroupement familial et alain juppé lui
même dit
la france ne peut pas être le seul où il
y a deux civilisations il ne peut pas y
avoir deux civilisations sur son sol ne
peut y avoir qu'une
donc c'est exactement tout ce que je dis
aujourd'hui trente ans plus tard je ne
dit pas autre chose
effectivement
parce que je pense que c'est que c'est
la vérité est que c'est le
la cause majeure du drame français
d'aujourd'hui c'est la cause majeure de
cette violence
qui qui qui s'est développée depuis en
france c'est la la la la base de 2,2 du
mal-être français de toutes ces enclaves
étrangères qui ont qui prolifèrent en
france et de 2
effectivement de
jeu si vous voulez je comprends à ce
moment là tout ce que je dis aujourd'hui
est que que je vais approfondir depuis
lors voilà
[Musique]